das macht mich einfach
ich möchte alles was du willst dich
nicht erinnern mit ihrem mann die
highstreet und das ist und das ist die
zweite schwester mit ihrer familie auch
und das ist meine zwei nicht
verheiratete schwester vater und mutter
und das die dritte familie meine
schwester noah mit ihrem anliegen im
november 2013 hat basel massa seine
angehörigen aus syrien in die schweiz
holen können
wie ist es wenn man die flucht geschafft
habt sind krieg aber in sich trägt davon
waren liegt dieser film
barschel nasa hat seinen verwandten die
flucht ermöglicht
er ist seit fünf jahren mit einer
schweizerin verheiratet noch muss er
alles für sie übersetzen
und du bist du klein
die elfjährige mais gehört zu einer der
vier syrischen familien die zusammen in
die schweiz flüchten konnten
weil er onkel schon hier lebte jetzt
nach den frühlingsferien in einen
kleinen cops mp3 woche und nachher nach
zwei tage ich starte mit dem gymnasium
ja ich bin aber ich habe angst auch aber
das gefällt
und du weißt nach den ferien zu normal
span bist du das letzte war in die
schule gegangen
in syrien wir gehen in einen staat das
nicht so viel nur ihrem balkon in der
schule gehängt in syrien aber wir mal
übersehen und alles können nicht in der
schule gehören irgendwie schwierig viele
prostitution ich informiere mich täglich
im internet im fernsehen
es ist einfach schrecklich was passiert
aber ich habe ja sonst nichts zu tun
basel ist oft bei seinen verwandten zum
übersetzen im durchgangszentrum ein
schwager von ihm hat ein stück erde zum
bearbeiten bekommen solche sachen und
vor allem dank der sich mit etwas
beschäftigt hat das erinnert ihn an die
pflanzung in sillian
die anderen judoka 10.30 weg damit und
eine gelassenere und dann ist ja
natürlich daran wachsen transfer
superfroh in der onyx aber wenn ich zb
sich mit dem motto vision ist isra
blitzableiter dennis der drang nach
die eltern mit den unverheirateten
töchter wohnen seit einem tag in diesem
provisorium das haus soll später
abgebrochen werden
sie durften als erste aus dem zentrum
ausziehen weil das familienoberhaupt
krank ist
er hat krebs
ich freue mich sie zu sehen
die elfjährige meist besucht ihre
großeltern um zu übersetzen
die begeisterung über die wohnung ist
groß in den letzten jahren auf der
flucht mussten alle familienmitglieder
auf privatsphäre verzichten
kuchen online toilettenanlagen sind wir
alleine auch ich will studieren
inspirierende zimmer kein problem und
ense hand kann nicht studieren immer
kinder im saal und meine schwester ich
glaube dass sie noch keine möbel haben
stört sie nicht
und wie geht es mit der schule
[Musik]
ich kann das nicht dann das was machst
du mit der schule kostet deutsch und
nachher irgendwas machen weil ich bin 22
jahre gar nicht gehen nach schule ich
will gehen nach löhne müsse die odl weiß
nicht was machen und was möchtest du
studieren wenn du dort kannst vielleicht
ist der in sillian bei vollständigem
eines tier in syrien
die anderen sind noch im letzten jahr
[Musik]
nach zehn monaten warten die eltern von
mais und danach immer noch auf den
sogenannten transfer also auf eine
wohnung
ich war das eingerichtet hat oder
gemacht hat ist der leider jetzt
umgezogen und wo sie das dach bären neu
oder vor einem monat glaube ich
umgezogen und sie wollen jetzt am stand
straße und werden
und was passiert mit ihnen beiden kinder
sehr gut in der schule sehr gut man aus
dem gymnasium das zuhause von mann am
eis und ihren eltern ist dieses zimmer
in den ersten wochen mussten sie es mit
einer anderen familie teilen die 17
jährige mann am pakt für das erste
klassenlager ihres lebens ich bin froh
weil ich konnte gymnasium gehen aber ich
bin auch nicht so frei jetzt weil also
ich muss viel machen
also wir haben schon also der schule
estland und dann habe ich zwei deutsche
sind und einen französischkurs und ich
muss alles mitmachen wenn du in serie
wäre es weißt du vielleicht schon
verheiratet glaube ich nicht weil nur
die menschen die sie nicht in der schule
gehen sie heute schon ein bisschen froh
aber die
wenn wir nicht in der schule gehen
glaube 15 16 bis 18 sind sie natürlich
heiraten
aber so wie ich und der hof und rama
wenn wir in der schule gehen und dann
müssen wir noch in der bühne gehen dann
haben wir nicht so viel biss der
universität fertig ist die universität
fertig ist dann ich glaube nicht dass
jetzt noch niemand weiß sie wird schon
in ein paar monaten eine eigene familie
gründen
jetzt brauchst nicht mehr klein ist
alles schon gut gewürzt und saubere dass
ihre familie ist erst vor einem monat
aus dem durchgangszentrum ausgezogen
weil es müsste jetzt eigentlich die
schule wechseln nicht eine andere schule
zu gehen
ich hoffe dass ich dort bleiben kommen
weil dort gefällt ich will einfach eben
wir den sekundarschulen gefällt es dir
so gut wie geht das mit deinen eltern
hast du immer ein bisschen kraft wenn
ich mich nicht helfen
[Musik]
sie fragen mich im postkasten hilfe
brauchen dann habe ich keine lust ihre
eltern haben im moment den traum von
einer rückkehr nach syrien aufgegeben
die situation in ihrer heimat ist
schlimmer als zuvor und es ist kein ende
abzusehen
darum wollen sie sich hier so schnell
und so gut wie möglich integrieren
in syrien hatten beide gute jobs in der
schweiz fangen sie wieder von vorne an
ich mache einen deutschkurs und ich
versuche vergessen französisch vergessen
nicht wir wissen nicht sprechen für sich
das ist an
ein deutsch kanton st wir müssen aber
wir haben probleme mit zuerst durch ist
schwierig und danach die menschen dort
sprechen
und ich denke ich brauche das ist
vielleicht gar nicht mehr sprechen aber
ohne kontakt das schwierig ja aber am es
denn es musste
[Musik]
ich mochte er
1 ff
aber ich habe 14 jahre gearbeitet in
syrien in labor und das möchten sie hier
auch er ein paar kilometer westlich in
bern bümpliz im ehemaligen pfarrhaus zur
gleichen zeit
der gehört mir ja hier hat auch hier
neuen boden gefunden seine familie und
die eltern seiner frau konnten für ein
paar monaten dieses neue provisorium
ziehen
es ist ihr dritter wohnsitz in der
schweiz hat ihre ankunft und es wird
nicht der letzte sein
heute haben sie wichtige post bekommen
es ist der positive asyl entscheid
er hat das alles bekommen für mich auch
kann man reisen und leben glücklich als
wir in der schweiz ankamen waren wir
schon sehr glücklich aber jetzt sind wir
noch kippen
basel kommt sofort um die gute nachricht
mit ihnen zu feiern
die eltern sind ihrem sohn sehr dankbar
jetzt sind sie damit sehr zufrieden dass
sie dass sie nicht nach syrien zurück
geschickt werden könnten und dass sie
sehr zufrieden damit sind
[Musik]
ist sehr gut integriert ich hab sie ist
analphabet frau und schaut nie gedacht
dass sie es schafft mit dem bus allein
und da das sie aussteigt einsteigt so
der zu den adressen zu gehen dass sie
sich mit der kultur ein bisschen
auskennt doch jetzt mit der zeit kann
sie selber fahren geht es zuerst in
alleine
sie macht viele dinge alleine hier in
der schweiz die sie nicht in sillian
machen konnte und wie immer wenn es ganz
schlimm oder ganz schön ist wird viel
gekocht und gegessen bei den syrischen
familie ihr verlobter russell hast du
was er hat gesagt ja und er sagt ich bin
zurückkommen nach aufkommt und ich im
familie nach 201
ich frage dann ich sage von meinem
bruder du weißt schon er ist für deine
freunde guter mann aber deine meinung
ist voll und ich habe gesagt okay
und jetzt habt ihr euch verlockt er sagt
was auf dich gemacht
ein mann von musik kommt und schrott am
papier dann meine haare schauen und so
und wir machen einen kleinen party in
the house und dann erst kommt ihr denn
woche nach dem ramadan und dann dann ich
möchte studieren auch in westlichen aber
dass er hat gesagt okay du kannst deine
studien komplett und so das sehr gut
fühle mich von habe ja schon eine frau
und sie ist studieren auch einmal mehr
kam alles anders
die heirat war ein jahr später knapp vor
der geburt ihres kindes das studium muss
jetzt warten
die inzwischen 14-jährige mais hat vor
zwei monaten unverhofft einen kleinen
bruder bekommen
ihre mutter hat wegen der
schwangerschaft ihren stellenantritt in
einem spital labor um ein paar monate
verschieben müssen
ihr vater mohammed hat seit einer woche
eine befristete praktikumsstelle bei des
whiskys foundation schon noch schön
april ist komme ich nach 14 jahren und
ein bisschen anstrengend für mich es ist
nicht zu denken
was wirst du deinen bruder erzählen
lassen wenn einmal sprechen kann nicht
so viel
es gibt momente da kann man einfach
nicht reden
schon gar nicht wenn man 14 ist und den
krieg noch in sich trägt
der krieg dauert jetzt über fünf jahre
ihre heimat gibt es nicht mehr
den eltern hilft es verwandte einzuladen
kusey der 12 jährige kussa von mais wenn
das neue baby kennenlernen möchte auch
noch vorgeschlagen
[Musik]
war nicht mit zur heimat und opposition
an
einfach so
[Musik]
hier finden sie sicher diese kinder aus
syrien doch sie tragen den krieg in sich
damit müssen sie leben lernen
die geschichte von kuh sei heute in
einer woche bei reporter
[Musik]